[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes videos ist für mich und für
hamster total besonders denn es startet
wieder meine ramadan reihe mittlerweile
im vierten jahr ist das zu fassen die
vier terra x -reihe angefangen vor vier
jahren kennen
da habe ich nur die hände gezeigt also
das kommt sich dann ja das stimmt und
jetzt spreche ich zu euch face to face
quasi und ich möchte heute mit der am
start mit einem device und haben wir
auch immer eine quatscht im ersten video
das können wir jetzt auch machen so ganz
locker ich zeige euch wie ihr einen
ramadan kalender machen könnt und
nebenbei wird noch ein bisschen quatsch
die idee ist folgende wir nehmen uns
jetzt etwas ich habe erst mal überlegt
einen kleiderbügel dann mach ich mir
nehmen sie nicht so schön oft ihr könnt
jetzt aber nehmen ist es auch kein
problem könnte es dann schön verkleiden
mit blumen zum beispiel und der
heißklebepistole der hamza und da werde
ich richtig stolz auf dich dass du das
gekauft hast der hat vor einem jahr
dass sie gekauft also der zum prozess
geschickt was glaube ich in der stadt um
ein solches mitnehmen ich bin kochen
ach so ja ist ja das passt ja fast immer
hat es gekauft
ich muss ehrlich zugeben auf das schön
aus als wenn mir rüber geschickt hat und
gefragt ob das holen sei und seitdem
liegt einfach nur im schrank rum und
jetzt habe ich mir gedacht perfekt das
findet ihr eigentlich fast überall also
läuft man nicht durch die stadt obwohl
aktuell corona phase ist ein bisschen
schwierig aber vielleicht habt ihr auch
jemanden der so was der heirat ansonsten
nimmt gern kleiderbügel und das möchte
ich jetzt trotzdem noch ein bisschen
verschönern hier sind zwar schon blumen
dran ihr könntet auch noch weitere
blumen brand leben mit der
heißklebepistole aber ich mache das
jetzt so dass den halbmond reinkommt so
und das schneiden wird jetzt allererstes
aus so falls ja auch probleme habt
irgendwie ein halbmond zu zeichnen nimmt
euch einfach zwei torten ringe zwei
schüsseln irgendwas was sie da habt ihr
ja das macht ja nichts man kann auch
zwei schüsseln nehmen oder deckel von
irgendwas dann einfach ein zeichen und
dann kann man sich das ganz einfach
ausschneiden ich hab es schon
vorbereitet so genau so sieht es dann
aus und sind total ästhetisch also kann
man nichts sagen
jetzt schnappt ihr euch dieses
erzeugt ihr könnt auch doppelseitiges
klebeband nehmen oder zum beispiel
heißkleber genau irgendwie sowas hab den
namen jetzt auch nicht mehr im kopf aber
jetzt drücke ich das einfach dran und
fertig was sagt ihr
ich finde es was sagst du schön also ich
finds ja warum
ja klar es kommt er jetzt noch alles
aber vorab warum immer die mondsichel
das ist vielleicht auch noch mal ein
ganz interessantes thema für die
nichtmuslime unter uns ihr wisst ja die
romanreihe ist für jeden ich hab erst
vorgestern noch eine nachricht bekommt
von ramona dass sie sagte ich bin
christin und freue mich wahnsinnig auf
deiner ramadan reihe weil sie die
orientalischen rezepte immer mag
aber zurück zum mond sich warum immer
das symbol es liegt einfach daran dass
man im islam nach dem mondkalender geht
und der ramadan das ist der name des
neunten monats und wenn die mondsichel
gesichtet wird dann beginnen wir zu
fasten und dann vergehen 29 oder je nach
dem 30 tage und wenn sie dann erneut
gesichtet wird dann gibt es das ja man
sagt zuckerfest mir gefällt das wort
nicht so
es hat sich irgendwann mal
eingebürgerten ja ich glaube wenn man
den kindern ja irgendwie nah oder weil
man den kindern immer zucker gibt aber
eigentlich ist es zum beispiel im
typischen ramazan bayrami beim bayram
das kennt ihr alle oder im arabischen
dass auch wofür soll ich kann sich so
gut aussprechen
aber genau so sieht's aus und jetzt
fehlen ja noch die tierchen die päckchen
die 30 stück und die machen jetzt auch
keine 12 oder auch 920 sie immer sehr
überraschend so und jetzt hole ich mir
alles und zeigt euch dann nehme ich das
mache
so jetzt nehme ich mir hier solche typen
die könntet ihr auch kürzer schneiden
damit sie vielleicht kleiner sind ich
weiß ja nicht was ihr verschenken möchte
es kommt auch immer darauf an wie alt
ist das kind oder wie alt ist er
erwachsen das ist ja auch eine schöne
idee für erwachsene
ich werde so machen das ist das kleine
schwester schenken
nein ich für dich aber wieder wenn du
das siehst kann sich schon mal freuen
das bringt mir die auf jeden fall morgen
vorbei aber den inhalt verrate ich noch
nicht damit sie es nicht sieht aber ich
habe mir so ein paar beispiele zum
beispiel was immer gegner also
schokolade oder selbst gebacken
damit schokolade die ist man einfach so
die müsste jetzt nicht hier rein tun
aber darauf achten dass die tüten auch
lebensmittelecht inanny sowas macht
handcreme eine kleine süße oder kerzen
also für meine schwägerin er das jetzt
schwägerin das hat sich so alt an wert
ist die emilia jetzt genau bietet sich
halt gut an es kommt immer darauf an wer
system ist es am allerbesten
wir machen und das jetzt einfach und
ling uns so eine tüte und dann legt er
jetzt zum beispiel hier diese schokolade
rein dann machen wir die zu- und
schnappt uns ein klammer wichtig ist
richtig genau genau das ja da hast du
recht könnte man auf jeden fall kürzer
schneiden dann nehmt ihr euch so eine
klammer mit loch achtet darauf dass die
vorne so ein kleines loch habt dann
nehmen wir uns ganz einfach von diesem
ort isa genau kordel baumwolle schnur
und schieden die einfach dadurch dass
machen wir 29 oder 30 mal
[Musik]
da erste station ist fertig das muss ich
mir noch überlegen was sie nicht anders
er ist vielseitig stimmt und ihr könnt
jetzt auch beschriften wenn ihr möchtet
dass zum beispiel der beschenkte das
immer am bestimmten tag aufmacht oder
ich mache das so ich mache 29 meine ich
auch nochmal sicherlich noch 29 mal
kleinigkeit rhein und im dreißigsten
türchen dann kommt was besonderes und
das markiert dann einfach mit einem
sternchen obendrauf
genau das ist mein geschenk kommt da
natürlich das besondere freien genauso
machen
es ist gerade die idee gekommen weil das
doch so süß aussieht mit dem sternchen
dass wir jetzt einfach überall ein
sternchen dran machen und dann doch die
zahlen drauf schreiben haben
[Musik]
fertig ist deshalb man kramer 1 kalender
ich finde ich richtig richtig schön also
mir gefällt der sehr gut ich würde mich
auch sehr freuen über so ein exemplar
nur leider machen wir das niemand aber
es nicht schlimm dass ich sie so schnell
ist es auch günstig also macht es gerne
nach ich wünsche euch jetzt viel freude
beim nachmachen viel freude bei unserer
ramadan reihe euch erwarten
orientalische rezepte rund um den globus
nicht nur türkisch nicht nur arabisch
wir machen was albanische sach ich
fahrrad einfach nicht so viel
ihr könnt euch einfach überraschen
lassen und dann könnt ihr euch auch
gerne die anderen eine führungs videos
von den letzten jahren angucken haben
auch ein bisschen mehr
ja wir haben also heute aber jetzt nicht
so viel über ja über tieferes gesprochen
dass ich bei den anderen malen gemacht
heute sollte es einfach nur ein hübsches
detail werden und ich freue mich wenn
ihr zahlreich einschaltet teilt fleißig
erzählt euren schwestern brüder tanten
onkels allen die ihr kennt verbreitet
die nachricht ist ramadan reihe ist
wieder da und dann sehen wir uns bei
meinem nächsten rezept cherokee und der
hand war
[Musik]